this
hearing will come to order
and be because of the technicality that
a
power sharing agreement has not yet been
signed between the majority leader and
the minority leader
i am chairing this hearing today
and i want to thank senator cantwell for
her
cooperation as we move toward the
transition and perhaps
for the next hearing we'll have a
symbolic
passing of the gavel but
um i i want to convey my
commitment and expectation that as we
move forward we'll continue to work
together in a bipartisan manner
on the vital issues that come before
this committee in the last congress that
bipartisan approach led to more than 50
public laws being enacted
out of this committee this cooperative
spirit will extend
to the confirmation process for
president biden
and i am absolutely delighted today that
the first of these
nominees submitted for our consideration
is mayor pete
butterjej to be secretary of
transportation
mayor buda judge has impressive
credentials which demonstrate his
intellect and commitment to serving
our nation as a former local elected
official
he will bring a valuable perspective to
the department of transportation
regarding the transportation
infrastructure needs and challenges of
towns and cities
throughout our country his educational
background
as a harvard graduate and rhodes scholar
at oxford university
will serve our country well as we
address our nation's transportation
policy priorities i also want to thank
him for his service as an
intelligence officer in the u.s navy
reserve
i also at this point want to thank
outgoing
secretary former secretary of
transportation elaine chao
for the professional and principled
manner in which she
has directed the department for the past
four years and i salute her on her
accomplishments
as uh once again a member
of a presidential cabinet i look forward
to hearing from mayor buddha judge today
on his and president biden's goals for
the department of transportation
should he be confirmed as secretary and
i'm quite certain
he will be confirmed i know this is only
the beginning of our dialogue about key
matters including
implementation of the momentous coveted
legislation passed by congress
which provides assistance to key
transportation sectors
such as aviation infrastructure
investment on how to improve
infrastructure in small towns in rural
communities
including using financing tools such as
advanced refunding
or creating taxable infrastructure
bonds promoting transportation
safety and coordination with state and
local governments and other stakeholders
further advancing transportation
innovation
including autonomous vehicles and drones
building up on our transportation
networks including our ports
highways and rail systems including
our national passenger rail system
amtrak and in that connection addressing
one of my top
priorities restoring amtrak service
along the gulf coast
where it was halted after hurricane
katrina
some 15 years ago these issues are
significant for
all mississippians and all
washingtonians
and all americans and i'm grateful that
mayor buddha judge is here today
to provide his views and i'm grateful
that he is willing to serve i want to
thank
mayor buda judge for testifying today
and at this point
i turn to my dear friend and colleague
the soon-to-be chair of this committee
senator cantwell thank you mr chairman
and i certainly appreciate the great
uh collegial working relationship that
we
have established thus far and i look
forward to
growing it in this congress
as you know we were able to work
together productively and pass landmark
aviation safety legislation
and many other pieces of legislation
including a coast guard bill that
moved out of this committee and then on
to other moving legislation
and successfully implemented into law so
thank you for that
productivity among other legislative
priorities i do want to take a second
since we have both
the members of our committee who were
able to successfully pull off
yesterday's celebration just thank
senators blunt and klobuchar for getting
us safely through
yesterday and and having it the
magnificent celebration that it was
hear him and look forward to uh
working with them and uh
certainly want to again thank
uh as you mentioned secretary chao for
her
work on many transportation priorities
i think this committee is a hallmark of
bipartisan cooperation
a lot of the subjects we deal with are
just hard problems to solve
and we've been able to continue to work
together
in a bipartisan fashion so i hope that
will continue and i think
transportation of all the sectors that
we deal with transportation should be
one of those
which we should be able to use facts and
information and come together
on priorities so i am
very excited that the president has
nominated
mayor pete buttigieg to run the
transportation
agency and i look forward to his vision
in leading that department of
transportation as a mayor
i know you're no stranger to the
challenges that a region faces
on transportation infrastructure issues
i know that you earned national
recognition for your smart streets
project that created a safe environment
for all road users
the project resulted in over 100 million
in private sector investment
you used your experience as mayor to
help
forge that and i hope that you will do
that for communities across the united
states of america
for us in the state of washington we're
a big export state
not only do we export our own products
so everything from
cherries and wheat and apples and
airplanes but
we also are a big pass through for many
of the midwest agricultural products
reaching
asia destinations so to say that we need
infrastructure investment
is an understatement the growth of the
pacific and the demand for u.s
products is a good problem to have we
just need to deal with the bottlenecks
and congestion in puget sound is at
record levels
we need to address projects like the i5
columbia river bridge replacement the
west seattle bridge replacement the
north south corridor in spokane
and we need to make infrastructure
investment all around the united states
of america
including in public transportation
projects
like sound transit are facing a one
billion dollar
shortfall as a result of cobit 19
which jeopardizes the much needed
investment throughout
puget sound today marks the one year
anniversary of the first
case of the covid uh
uh pandemic with a man from everett
washington
being tested positive one of the most
impacted sectors in the united states
not the only sector but one of the most
impacted sectors in the united states
has been transportation
the chairman alluded to the fact that
this committee played a very aggressive
role
in trying to come up with solutions for
the impacts to the transportation
sector whether that was aviation or most
recently
with infrastructure and with amtrak but
that will continue
the needs to move product and people
will continue whether we have a coveted
pandemic or not and so i hope that you
will help us
in facing these short falls
i also want to point out that as i
mentioned the movement of freight
is particularly important and we will
look forward to your leadership in
moving
improved ways to move freight around the
united states
i continue to think that the legislation
that ended up being in the infogram
program was very helpful to states
across the united states
and i just want to mention the fact that
aviation safety and security and the
legislation that this
uh committee passed and was implemented
into law
has to now uh be administered by the
department of transportation and the faa
so we're going to be looking for your
leadership
your success and holding them
accountable to the many aspects of that
legislation
and helping us move forward if we want
to be the leaders in the united states
of america
on aviation we have to be the leaders in
aviation safety as well so we'll look
for
your leadership on that so mr chairman
i'm excited about this
nominee's ability to help us focus on
uh transportation issues and look
forward to seeing his leadership
at the department thank you thank you
very much
senator klobuchar and at this point uh
it is my pleasure
to um recognize
our distinguished colleague from the
state
of indiana a member of this committee
senator young
to introduce our witness well hello
chairman wicker
ranking member can't well members of the
committee it's my distinct pleasure
to introduce a fellow hoosier as
president biden's nominee for
secretary of transportation mayor put
pete
pete and i have known one another for a
number of years
he's a professional friend and colleague
and
someone for whom i have a great deal of
respect
on the off chance that members of this
committee were not paying attention
during the 2020 presidential democratic
primaries
i'll quickly recap buddha judge's uh
background pete was born in south bend
indiana
where he went on to serve as mayor for
two terms from 2012 to 2020
and as mayor he invested in important
infrastructure
improvements and facilitated
public-private partnerships
that made those dollars go much further
indiana's long been a leader in these
public-private partnerships a model that
will be very important for
future infrastructure investments
mayor buddhagedge was also a supporter
of the south shore double track project
whose full funding grant agreement was
signed earlier this month
like many state and local projects the
department of transportation awards
funding toward
the the south shore double track
required remarkable coordination between
federal state and local leaders to make
the project
a reality and to get it across the
finish line
while mayor he also served our country
as a united states navy reservist
from 29 2009 to 2017
including a deployment to afghanistan in
2014 he's a graduate
of harvard college 2004 and he attended
oxford
on a rhodes scholarship transportation
is a vital sector to the hoosier state
we're in the top 10 states when it comes
to railroad mileage
we have world-class airports 66 public
transit systems three ports and our
state motto
is the crossroads of america i've
traveled
tens of thousands of miles on on those
roads and i know pete has as well
if mayor buddha judge is confirmed and i
believe he will be
i hope he will be i look forward to
working with him and my colleagues here
on this committee to maintain and
improve the infrastructure
that drives the american economy thank
you mr chair
thank you very very much senator young
and mr mayor you are
recognized for your opening statement
delighted to have you
thank you very much mr cantwell uh
members of the committee it's a real
honor to be able to appear before you as
nominee for the secretary of
transportation and
let me begin just first by thanking my
home state senator young for for your
kind introduction
for your service to our shared home
state and to our country
and to your attention to south bend
during the time that i was mayor thank
you
i want to thank president biden for
trusting me with this nomination
and i'd like to take a moment to
introduce my husband chasten buttage
who's
here with me today i'm uh really proud
to have him by my side i also want to
take this chance
to thank him for his many sacrifices and
his support
in making it possible for me to pursue
public service
today i hope to present to you my goals
for the department of transportation
to share a little bit about myself and
of course to hear from you about your
priorities
for the department the issues that you
consider important
uh for your constituents and for our
country
first and foremost i want you to know
that if confirmed
i will work every day to make sure the
department meets
its mission of ensuring safety safety
for both travelers and for workers and
i look forward to working closely with
congress to do so
safety is the foundation of the
department's mission
and that takes on new meaning amid this
pandemic
we have to ensure that all of our
transportation systems
our aviation and public transit our
railways roads
ports our waterways and pipelines all of
it is managed
safely in this critical period as we
work to defeat the virus for good
we also have a lot of work to do to
improve the infrastructure in this
country
a mission that will not only keep more
people safe but will grow our economy
as we look to the future now is the time
and
i believe we have a real chance to
deliver for the american people
we need to build our economy back better
than ever
and the department of transportation can
play a central role in this
by implementing president biden's
infrastructure vision
by creating millions of good-paying jobs
revitalizing communities that have been
left behind
enabling american small businesses
workers
families and farmers to compete and win
in the global economy
and tackling the climate crisis
infrastructure can be the cornerstone to
all of this and you have my commitment
that i will work
closely with you to deliver the
innovation
and the growth that america needs in
this area
as a mayor from the industrial midwest i
will bring a bottom-up perspective
on transportation programs and funding
if confirmed i'm looking forward to
working with our partners at the state
local territorial and tribal levels as
well to find
solutions to our infrastructure issues
while we also prepare for the future of
transportation
at a time of great change when i took
office as mayor of south bend a city
built by the power of american
transportation we had been hit
so hard by economic loss that some in
the national press listed us as one of
america's
dying cities as our city fought its way
out of the teeth of the great recession
infrastructure was at the heart of our
vision for a better future
as mayor i worked with public and
private partners to launch a smart
streets initiative that
brought new life to our urban core and
to the historically underserved west
side of our city
revitalize revitalizing our downtown
redesigning streets
and spurring hundreds of millions in
major economic investment
i worked with regional and state
partners and across the aisle to support
enhancements to our inter-city train
system that senator young
mentioned the south shore line and our
now international airport
as we pioneered public-private
partnerships at the same time
like commuters trust the benefits
program to
improve the city's transportation
experience for workers
we got results by bringing people in
engaging stakeholders and residents
prioritizing limited funds effectively
and unlocking new resources to solve
problems and that is how i will approach
the trans
the department of transportation if
confirmed
i believe good transportation policy can
play no less a role
than making possible the american dream
getting people
and goods to where they need to be
directly and indirectly creating
good-paying jobs but i also recognize
that
at their worst misguided policies and
missed opportunities in transportation
can reinforce racial and economic
inequality
by dividing or isolating neighborhoods
and undermining government's basic role
of empowering americans to thrive
so much is at stake today and so much is
possible
as our country works to emerge from the
crises of this moment
with bipartisan appetite for a
generational opportunity
to transform and improve america's
infrastructure so the chance to lead
this department at this historic moment
is not one that i take lightly
and have confirmed i promise to bring
the same sense of duty
and commitment that led me to serve my
hometown as mayor
and that motivated me to serve our
country in the navy reserve
to conclude chairman wicker ranking
member can't well members of the
committee
i am eager to get to work and if
confirmed look forward to
partnering with this committee and with
congress and i look forward to your
questions now
thank you very much mayor bruce jensen
we will begin questions
under the five-minute rule first of all
let's talk
about passenger rail and about amtrak
the secretary of transportation or his
or her destiny serves as a member of the
amtrak board of
directors which has 10 members the u.s
department of transportation
also is responsible for administering
federal grants
to amtrak and overseeing inner city
passenger rail policy
as i mentioned in my opening statement a
priority of mine has been
restoration of the gulf coast rail
service
which we've been waiting for for some 15
years
this is an undertaking that i and many
others have been working on
and in 2019 the southern rail commission
received a chrissy grant award of 33
million dollars
for this project but there is much more
to do
um mayor buddhijudge
early in your term as
secretary would you have an interest in
coming to mississippi
to see the gulf coast route from
new orleans through the gulf coast of
mississippi
and onto mobile i would thank you for
the invitation chairman i'd love the
opportunity
and if confirmed would you be committed
to working with me to reinstate amtrak
service
after this long 15-year hiatus
i look forward to uh working with you to
learning more
as you know uh i'm probably only the
second biggest uh
passenger rail enthusiast in this
particular administration
i think you discussed that uh with me
and elaborated on it during our
conversation
over the phone you would you enjoy uh
actually traveling
on amtrak i do i enjoy uh uh long train
trips as well as short ones and i i
think that
americans ought to be able to enjoy the
highest standard of passenger rail
service
mr mayor this committee will uh will
consider multi-modal transportation
discretionary grant
programs when it reauthorizes our
surface transportation programs
grant programs like build grants
infra and the port program play an
important role in addressing
infrastructure needs
across the country and are particularly
critical
for small towns and rural communities if
confirmed how do you plan to utilize
these programs
to ensure rural communities are not left
behind so build in front other
grant programs are i believe a central
part of how we're going to be able to
deliver on that goal
of enhancing infrastructure resources
for
all americans and i recognize especially
coming from a community of the size of
south bend
knowing that there are smaller
communities than ours
but also at our size we're not among
those that were able to have a
full-time staff working on federal
relations it's very important to me to
make sure that
this process is user-friendly that
criteria are transparent
and that communities of every size
including rural communities and smaller
communities
have every opportunity to access that
funding
if you could spend the next two minutes
uh elaborating and perhaps you'll have a
chance
uh later on with other senators on
our new president's vision for
a massive infrastructure program
and how intense to propose that we pay
for this
so this is i think our opportunity to
literally do the building part in build
back better
and uh of course there are a lot of
conversations that still need to happen
not only within the administration but
with members of this committee
and the congress on exactly how to shape
how to time
and how to fund that opportunity but a
lot of this
also is part and parcel of what has to
happen
by way of the economic recovery uh that
uh this administration needs to
support and drive in the wake of cobit
i mean chairman please go ahead yes well
that means making sure that uh every
part of our transportation
infrastructure gets
those kinds of investment and i believe
that there are
certainly challenges in funding any of
the different modes of transportation
for example
we know that the highway trust fund has
more going out than coming in
but for the regular transfers from
general fund that
that are being authorized by this
congress i think we need to develop more
sustainable
and predictable means of delivering that
kind of funding
uh it's a major challenge and one that
can be answered outside of the context
of a partner with
a partnership with congress but i also
think there's a a historic opportunity
in terms of the support that i've heard
from members of this committee
on on both sides of the aisle in our
conversations and from the public to
actually put together the resources to
make those kinds of investments whether
we're talking about
uh trains planes and automobiles or next
generation
transportation opportunities
subject for uh much more conversation
over the next few weeks and months thank
you very much uh senator cantwell
thank you mr chairman and so i'm gonna
try to as quick go
through a whole variety of things as
quick as possible so just
if you can help me out there that would
be great one just want to clarify the
chairman did a great job of talking
about infra and build and your support
for it
do you think we need a significant
investment in that i look at what um
in 2018 we were 18.9 trillion worth of
worth of goods shipped uh in the united
states
and that is expected to increase by 40
percent
so i look at that and say that's part of
our economic strategy get exports get
them to market quickly so
would you say we need a significant
increase in those programs
infra and build absolutely there needs
to be a major investment in order to
deliver
okay uh would you say that the issue
of at-grade crossings is also an issue
that might need more attention
we just had a derailment in the
northwest we have a lot
of uh traffic moving through our
communities and
we hear constantly about safety issues
do you think that
at-grade crossings need more attention
yes okay
um on aviation i mentioned in my opening
statement about the issues of
the legislation we passed and getting
the faa
to do its oversight role there was a
report by rank and file faa
employees that 49 of the employees
responded indicating they believe safety
concerns or incidents
would not were not being addressed and
that 43
believe the faa delegated too much so
we've tried to focus
our attention here on that issue
but uh in describing the engagement
with aviation one faa employee said it
feels like i'm showing up to a knife
fight with
nerf weapons so i want to know that you
will make the safety reforms at the faa
a priority i'm committed to doing so we
need to make sure that
engineers and the faa are in the
driver's seat when it comes to safety
and
we'll be working right away to implement
the legislation that you've advanced
with regard to ensuring that we have
every confidence and safety at the faa
are you willing to make changes in
personnel if necessary
yes thank you um i want to go back
to transportation
again sorry here a lot of things
we want to ask you about uh
the uh one uh primary tool for dot
to support transit agency is the capital
investment grant program
would you support increasing a federal
share of funding for grants
to the recently approved project to
ensure the pandemic does not halt or
delay
transportation investments i'll
certainly want to take a look at this i
think uh often uh we have not uh created
as much predictability and capital
uh planning as we have on the
operational side and i'd be eager to
look at how we can better fund that okay
and back to
aviation manufacturing my colleague i'm
sure will be here sometime today
senator moran uh senate uh chairman
wicker mentioned a lot of the
kova dollars that were said to focus on
aerospace and to focus on aerospace
manufacturing
we want to make sure that aerospace
manufacturing
impacted again because of the lack of
demand
in air travel we don't lose that skill
and workforce so we want to
know that you will help us make aviation
manufacturing a priority and making sure
that
retaining a workforce in the united
states is as important as retaining the
workforce that we see in our air
transportation today and the flights and
flight attendants and pilots
certainly it's important both
economically and strategically for the
country so you have my commitment
thank you and then lastly um uh
i am a big jones act supporter
and uh the state of washington and the
trade that we have
related to the jones act to to make sure
that we have
uh u.s flagged uh vessels
sometimes it gets under attack but i
just want to hear that you support the
jones
act yes i share your support for the
jones act it
is so important to a maritime industry
that creates hundreds of thousands of
jobs as well as the shipbuilding
industry here in the u.s
okay thank you let's see i think that
senator thune thank you madam chair
um mayor thank you for being here today
um
as this committee considers your
nomination for secretary of
transportation
transportation infrastructure investment
around here has always been an area for
bipartisan cooperation as evidenced by
passage of the fast act which enjoyed
wide popularity in congress
and among the states the other thing
that enjoys
uh bipartisan popularity around here is
not paying for it um you know
we continue to just hand it put it on
the debt and hand the bill to our kids
and grandkids
and i i know this isn't the place for
you to get specific about
ways to pay for it you'd be crazy to do
that at a hearing like this
but i just want to put on your radar
screen that these investments that we
want to make and roads and bridges and
highways and all those things
we have to address the issue how we
finance it the
environment public works committee
reported a bill out last session of
congress 21-0 out of the committee it
increased funding
for highways by 28 percent and the
reason it came out 21-0
is because they don't have to pay for it
it's all the spending side of it
um at some point and i serve also serve
on the senate finance committee we have
to figure out how we're going to pay for
it and
it's going to take presidential
leadership it's going to take bipartisan
cooperation
in the congress in order to make that
happen the fast act did include
strong investments in rural america
which are critical for states like south
dakota that rely on federal investment
transportation infrastructure to ensure
the efficient flow of goods in
to domestic and global markets freight
corridors
within rural areas are critical
component of the national transportation
system those investments benefit the
entire country
not just the rural areas highways and
railroads
in rural regions need to be connected to
our nation's major cities
which need the many products that
originate in places like the heartland
we have this conversation so it's
crucial
in my view that transportation policy
and investment continue to recognize the
importance of rural areas
where the vast majority of agricultural
industrial commodities originate
to keep the transportation system in
this country fluid dynamic and
interconnected
as we previously discussed i introduced
the rail
rehabilitation finance innovation act
along with senator hass and last
congress and it takes
important steps to improve the rif
credit review process
and increase utilization of the program
by short-line railroads
small connector lines in real estate
like south dakota provide a critical
service to farmers they carry grain
ethanol and other products from
terminals
to class one main lines if confirmed and
as we work to move this legislation
during 117th congress can you describe
how you would approach improvements
to freight rail policy and investment uh
well i look forward to working with you
to
learn more and develop this uh as you
mentioned this is one of the few
infrastructure programs that's actually
undersubscribed and so it points to the
need for
uh for more work to be done and i think
it's very important
for all the reasons that you just
described important to my home state as
well and
so many communities that we act on that
south dakota has
nine tribal reservations many of them
large and sparsely populated where
tribal roads
provide a crucial transportation linked
to many communities
for this reason i introduced the tribal
transportation equity
and transparency improvement act that's
a mouthful with senator cinema
last congress and among other provisions
the bill seeks to improve and update
data on tribal roads which is a critical
critical aspect of ensuring funds are
allocated where they are needed most
do you agree that tribal road funding
should be allocated according to the
most
up-to-date data i do would you commit to
working with me in this congress to
ensure that this important important
program is improved
i welcome that opportunity thank you
um let me just mention uh one other
issue here which i think
uh and this is something that state
particularly in rural areas like south
dakota
deal with and that's the lack of
resources to comply with a lot of the
burdensome federal administrative
requirements the fast act included
several provisions that were aimed at
easing administrative burdens for state
dots
and the bipartisan america's
transportation infrastructure act which
as i said was unanimously approved by
the environment public works committee
in the last congress
built on that success to provide state
dots with greater flexibility to manage
their transportation networks
should the federal government work with
state dots
to provide them the flexibility that
they need to build
and maintain our nation's transportation
infrastructure
so i believe any time that we can make
federal processes more
user-friendly for states or or or local
or tribal partners we should
and when we find that anything is
duplicative or burdensome
uh would welcome find way finding ways
to streamline that provided of course
that we're meeting the
fundamental goals of those rules safety
environmental or otherwise
right okay i hope that we can continue
to build on uh
some of the success successes that were
made in the last highway bill to
allow as much as flexibility as possible
so states can get the the
most resources on the target and i look
forward to working with you on that and
i see
my time has expired so madam chair i
yield back
mayor welcome thank you senator
klobuchar
well thank you very much senator
cantwell and thank you to senator wicker
welcome mayor pete i want to thank you
for being here i think you know how
excited i am about your
nomination and what a great
transportation secretary you will be
i know you well and i can attest to all
my colleagues
uh what a forward-thinking and
thoughtful uh secretary you will truly
be in a very important area for
all of us and for our nation and uh
john and i also look forward to seeing
you and chaston in a
less formal setting outside of this
hearing room
and i appreciate what you said about
transportation safety
it was in my state that the 35w bridge
collapsed in the middle of a summer day
bridge just shouldn't fall down in the
middle of america we lost 13 people and
many
injured and i guess i would start with
that can you
talk about your priorities for safety
you mentioned to the chairwoman and i
agree
incoming chairwoman and i agree with her
about um
rail crossings aviation uh but maybe you
want to mention bridges a little
you and i talked about the blotnick
bridge going from duluth
to superior wisconsin the second largest
bridge in my state that needs
rehabilitation we need to do work on
that
just any uh comments you have on bridge
safety as well as in general
yes first of all thanks for the for the
kind words and the warm welcome and
uh i agree i remember how outspoken you
were at the time of that
uh that bridge collapse and uh that just
shouldn't happen as you said
and so often states and counties other
local governments are expected to
maintain these bridges
but don't have the resources to do it
and so it's another example of how
we need a major and significant
investment as a safety concern
to enhance upgrade and maintain bridges
and
other key critical infrastructure assets
across the country
that is not going to be all under your
jurisdiction
um the one important piece of it is
which is how we figure out as we invest
in more broadband which we
know we so sorely need through this
pandemic and before and i know you've
devoted a lot of thought to this but we
also and
when we do road construction we can do a
better job of laying the broadband
lines at the same time it's called dig
once um and i wonder
what thoughts you have on that yeah this
is very important my own community uh
parts of south bend have
phenomenal uh broadband fiber
connectivity for the simple reason that
somebody remembered
to lay conduit alongside some of the
railway and highway right-of-ways that
connected us
to chicago to the west and so even if
this is
being driven by another department i
would welcome the opportunity to make
sure that d.o.t
side of the equation is open to
supporting that broadband deployment
because it's so important in so many
communities
um one thing i know you also understand
is the rural areas you have big rural
areas in
indiana and the senator thune touched on
this a bit but
for build grants capital investment
grants just talk about
uh your priorities to making sure those
go out in rural areas we have a lot i
see center tester here a lot of
centers here with areas with significant
rural areas so several things i think we
can do to make sure that rural
communities have have access and
equitable access to those grants
uh one is to make them more
user-friendly another is to ensure that
the criteria are very clear and that
there's feedback we know how it is for
my community to be a
runner-up sometimes in these processes
and the better your feedback is the more
you can
uh come back the next time and have a
better shot at it of course
the more resources go in to begin with
the more folks can get that favorable
answer right away
sometimes i think going back to what
used to be called earmarks they could be
called congressionally initiated
projects
uh would be helpful for especially for
some of the rural areas because
we have a good sense of what's going on
uh in our
in our states um you have done the work
with which was brought up before smart
streets
um your initiative to help improve
safety revitalize downtown south bend
and actually on a bipartisan basis we
i've been leading that recreational
trails program
funding and um
thank you for the note about my hair
sticking straight up doug
thank you that was really nice and
subtle um
but in any case um the uh the
the um recreational trails project
um is something that um
it would be actually the program applies
to both
uh recreational vehicles that are
non-motorized and motorized like
snowmobiles atvs and
we've worked this interesting coalition
uh with motorized non-motorized
uh for bikes and other things as well so
could you talk a little bit about that
that funding has been really important
especially in this pandemic where people
are looking for uh
recreation like that yes and thanks for
your leadership on this there there are
so many ways that uh people get around
and
i think often we've had an auto-centric
view that has forgotten historically
about
all the other different modes we want to
make sure any time we're doing
a street design that it enables cars and
bicycles and pedestrians and businesses
and any other mode uh to to co-exist in
in a positive way and we should be
putting funding behind that all right
excellent what's i said we're excited
that you are willing to serve and look
forward to working with you
thank you thank you thank you senator
blunt uh thank you senator cantwell
i'm mayor glad to have you here today
good to have a chance to talk
the other day and as you and i discussed
you know where
you live and where i live i think we
have a unique
view of the transportation hubs of the
country
and how important transportation is to
our economies
i've got about four minutes and 45
seconds here so let me see if i can
cover
for our five topics one in the fast act
i work to secure a provision
there that directed the advisory council
on historic preservation
to provide railroad right-of-way the
same general provision we give to
highways in other words if a
railroad has been there just like bay
highway has been there you don't have to
go through
all of the historic view of whether you
should continue to have a railroad there
and um so we would pass that
bill um the
council really has failed to provide the
relief
that was contemplated so we passed it
again in december we put language in in
december
to the council do what the congress told
you they needed to do
you needed to do in this area and again
almost exactly similar to what happens
in highways
if confirmed i have your commitment to
work with me and the federal railroad
administration to ensure the council
provides the general exemption
consistent
with congressional intent included in
the fast act
i'll make sure to work with you to make
sure that the congressional intent is
met
well i think it's a very logical thing
just like it was logical for highways it
is a different consideration
when you're putting something back or
repairing something or making something
making an improvement where where a rail
road has already been just like where
highways been
another topic i think you'd have
particular understanding
of where the experience you've had as
mayor and working with other mayors
essential air service and contract
towers
uh important to the ability to
have an aviation ecosystem
many people on this committee are
affected by those two things the
essential air service program and the
contract
tower program if you have any concerns
about
those programs not moving forward i'd
like to
know that now but otherwise i just like
your sense that you understand
the importance of these programs what
they mean to communities where they
qualify for them and the importance of
continuing to look at these
as as principal pillars of our aviation
system for those sizes of communities
yes i've been hearing a lot about eas
from you and your colleagues and
recognize how important that is also to
communities not too far from where i
live and so i believe that
uh that uh kind of support uh has a uh
every uh every reason to uh continue to
uh uh enjoy an important place in our
transportation policy
exactly and um you know both of um
the communities where you where you live
and i live in the states where we live
trucking's been an important part of
this for a long time
doesn't mean we don't need to do things
to have better intermodal
opportunities you know the rail hubs we
have we have the second third biggest
rail hubs
in america our kansas city and st louis
the interstate highways
come together in our state as they do in
yours in unique ways
the patchwork
of laws that would could
concern that interstate competition and
interstate commerce one of the
principal reasons given to have the
constitution is to facilitate that
a patchwork of different laws from
trucks moving from one
state to another incredibly complicated
i raised this issue in 2018
uh with secretary chao and she was um
able in 2018 to use specific authority
congress gave the secretary
narrowly she used it to narrowly preempt
california rules about meals and rest
breaks
that were different than the rules where
these trucks were coming from
they had been wrongly applied to
interstate
motor carriers um
she used that rule for preemption
of the state law in this circumstance
the ninth circuit last week unanimously
upheld her determination that this is
something
that the secretary could do uh and did
appropriately
my hope is that this issue is now
settled
but you know we've discussed it we've
debated it we've now litigated it
um i think it's really important that we
don't have
a patchwork of rules that someone
a someone driving a truck that's the way
they make their living going across the
country
has to worry about when they cross a
state line
uh what happens to them based on the
state they were just
in any you have any thoughts about that
so
i'd want to look more into some of the
specific case law you're discussing but
uh certainly uh recognize the importance
of uh consistency predictability
and uh the key of course is squaring
that with that that fundamental mission
of safety
well and the fundamental mission of
safety
is not necessarily advantaged by a
driver
having to think about how quickly they
have to get one state so they've got the
time they need in another state
you have the authority to do that if you
become
secretary and i hope you use that
authority
as secretary chao did and as the ninth
circuit
uh upheld again just this week
one final topic and i may have a
question or two for the record
in the cares act the secretary was given
the task of overseeing a number of
provisions that related
to extending support for airports
concessionaires
making sure that services are maintained
despite the challenges
we've gone through will you work with
the congress to authorize and implement
programs
which help provide a safe workplace for
transportation workers
but also which ensure that we have an
air system that's still there and a
car rental system that's still there
when our
air travel returns to
such a blow and they are so important to
our economy i look forward to working
with you to make sure we're doing
everything we can to support them thank
you thank you sir canwell you senator
blumenthal
finish we have
in this country an existential crisis in
our public transportation system you are
absolutely right they've taken a blow
and it may be a fatal blow for some of
the private companies that provide bus
transportation like gatco
in connecticut airports like bradley are
gravely at risk metro
north has suffered an 80 decline
in ridership rail in the northeast
is seriously in danger fiscally and
otherwise and
most important maybe from a human
standpoint
the employees of these transportation
networks
are seriously at risk right now
and i have sponsored a measure called
the
essential transportation employee safety
act which would provide more personal
protective equipment
more testing hopefully more vaccinations
to these
flight attendants train conductors
employees at airports all of these
essential workers
who are interacting every day with
people who may
put them at risk of covet and they have
suffered
serious losses so i would like your
commitment
to the safety of these
employees i know it's in your heart i
know you have that
sense of caring for them but we need
measures like
the one i've proposed and the
mass mandate order that the president
issued yesterday
which i hope also will be extended to
legislation as a
national mandate on federal property uh
yes you have that commitment in
in speaking with uh representatives of
workers we've heard about their exposure
to risks from
uh covet exposure all the way to assault
and we've got to make sure that
workers are safe in this field on a
matter also very close to home for a
number of us in
the northeast you're familiar with the
gateway project you and i
talked about it in our conversation
thank you by the way for
talking to me so extensively the other
day uh
the gateway program includes the hudson
tunnel
project incredibly
these tunnels are 111 years old
think of the era when they were built
the technology has changed magnificently
the tunnels
are decrepit degrading and
about to potentially collapse i'd like
your commitment that you will
move this project which is essential to
all rail traffic indeed all
transportation
in the northeast i know you will find a
lot of interest on the part of
my colleague senator schumer and
gillibrand as well as
murphy and others up and down the
northeast in the gateway project
and particularly the hudson tunnel
project yes i've heard this loud and
clear from from you and uh
your colleagues and counterparts in the
region and look forward to working with
you on this to move forward
and the same really applies to uh
the bridge across the connecticut
river which is
in serious need of repair
and even replacement it's a 550 million
dollar project i hope
it will be included in any broader
infrastructure program
and finally let me just close
my background is as a prosecutor i
believe in enforcing the laws
around here we make a lot of laws but
you know
as a former mayor how important law
enforcement is
and the dot i'm just going to be very
blunt
has failed again and again and again to
issue
regulations that are necessary to make
the law real in people's lives
under the 2018 faa reauthorization act
congress required the faa to issue a
rule
establishing minimum seat size and leg
room standards
for commercial flights and review cabin
evacuation procedures
pertaining to seat size within one year
many
many of us on this panel were
instrumental in passing that law
but the rules to implement it still have
not been issued
i would like your commitment that you
will devote
attention to rulemaking involving
are essential to enforcing these laws
yeah so i'll look into this and make
sure that the
the rulemaking is keeping pace with
congressional intent thank you
thank you so much thank you i think nix
is senator fisher who's joining us
remotely
thank you sen cantwell and uh thank you
mr buddha judge for being here today i
first off would like to just make a
couple comments
um senator cantwell spoke about the
jones act
and i am so privileged to represent
state nebraska
in the united states senate and we are
the only
uh triple landlocked state in the union
i am also a strong supporter of jones
act and recognize
the need for it and it is vital for the
security of this country uh also
senator blunt uh brought up comments
about the recent ruling uh by the ninth
circuit
and i would just like to associate
myself
with his comments i think it is a
decision that is uh
important for um for the
movement of our goods and services and i
believe
it is also recognizing the safety
involved in that but it is good
to have you here today mr buda judge
last week
nitsa issued a final rule updating
certain definitions
and vehicle crash worthiness standards
to account for automated
and passenger-less vehicles they also
said this is part of a series of actions
it is taking to modernize the federal
vehicle standards for new technologies
what are your thoughts on this and it's
a final rule
well automated vehicle technology is
coming it's advancing very quickly
it is something that holds the potential
to be transformative
and i think in many ways policy has not
kept up
uh i haven't had a chance to uh evaluate
uh this last step in detail but
i look forward to digging in on that and
more broadly
making sure that that we're acting so
that on the policy side we are
ready for all of the things that
automated vehicles are going to bring
to our roads and into our economy that's
great
because we all know that we need to
reexamine some of our current regulatory
framework
and i think that means that
flexibilities
in these regulations have have to be
exercised
if we're going to continue seeing
emerging technologies
have government keep up with the
advancement that we see in the private
sector
also last week fixa announced a pilot
program to study providing
truck drivers with greater flexibility
and split
sleeper birth requirements various
groups representing truck carriers and
drivers
including the teamsters have indicated
support for this type of flexibility
and comments to the agencies um
do you know about this proposed pilot
program
and uh what are your thoughts on that so
i'd want to take a closer look at this
and engage with the stakeholders as well
to make sure i understand uh
how this pilot program squares the uh
the the goals of
of worker and and traveler safety with
the goals of flexibility
i always think it's important when we
can bring a variety of stakeholders
together uh transportation
infrastructure is an issue
that receives uh strong support
uh across this country and within the
senate as well
so um it's it's in um it's in our
interest as a government to be able to
take
those comments from from all
stakeholders
in looking at any issue when we
when we spoke the other day sir i i
brought up
an issue about truck haulers
of agricultural commodities including
livestock haulers
and to be able to provide them with some
flexibility
in their hours of service requirements
in 2018 i offered a bipartisan amendment
to provide a 150
air mile radius hours of service
exemption on the destination
as well as eliminating what is known as
seasonality limitation of egg hours of
service exemption
and a bill that i introduced last year
the halls act
address these issues as well
but when we had our conversation i spoke
about
the really the challenges in moving
live animals perishable products
and and it's not easy to find
places to be able to unload a pot load
of cattle for example
and get them off a truck have them uh
have them in some kind of a facility in
a pen
and then reload them that's um puts more
stress on
on animals than that is necessary
and certainly more stress than is
advisable
so that is something that i hope you and
i can
work on together for the ag industry the
livestock industry
make sure that they they have the needed
flexibility and that their
thank you that was a memorable point
during our conversation that
uh sometimes our policies can't tell the
difference between uh
live animals and other cargo and it's
one of the things i'm eager to look into
and to work with you on as well
thank you i look forward to your
confirmation
and appreciate again the conversations
that we've had and look
thank you forward you senator cantwell
thank you
thank you uh senator schatz remotely
thank you madam chairman uh mr mayor
uh thank you for your willingness to
serve i want to start
uh with climate action uh the president
has instructed his entire cabinet
uh to take bold climate action not just
the epa not just the department of
energy but
every single executive agency and i'd
like for you to talk a little bit about
what kinds of authorities you feel dot
already has and what lines of
actions you can undertake right away and
how that
intersects with an infrastructure
package and the desire to
uh create a better economic future over
the next
six to 12 months thank you senators as
you correctly pointed out the president
has made it very clear that he expects
all of us to
work on delivering a new climate vision
and it's going to take a
whole-of-government approach and
certainly
d.o.t has a big part of this you think
about
the role involved in fuel economy
standards
vehicle electrification what we'd have
to do as a country to have the kinds of
charging station infrastructure uh just
represent a couple of examples
of how we can be part of the solution at
dot and i think that'll be
contemplated have to be contemplated in
as a central feature of any
infrastructure package um
i'd welcome the opportunity to work with
you on on how best to do this with the
most
possible impact because i also think we
have a unique window of opportunity to
make those kinds of investments and
we've got to use that window
thank you state and local budgets have
been
decimated by the pandemic transit
projects like heart which is the
honolulu
rail project is no exception
and are potentially at risk without
additional
federal support and just to
put a fine point on it a lot of these
projects are under a
an ffga an agreement with the federal
transit administration that assumed a
certain revenue picture
uh pre-pandemic that uh is not
reasonable anymore and so my question is
very simple do i have your commitment
to work on this and other projects to
make sure
um that all of our rail projects whether
they are pre-revenue or not
uh do not fall by the wayside and are
able to be implemented
yes we need to work together on this i
know how much these
transit agencies have been through
there's obviously some support in the
president's announced rescue package but
a lot more to do
thank you nitsa recently announced that
even though we drove fewer miles during
the pandemic
uh speeding fatalities and serious
injuries have increased what's happening
and how do we solve it
well over the course of my lifetime
we've made a lot of gains as a country
on dealing with
uh the effects of drunk driving on
road safety and fatalities only to see
distracted driving
rise uh to become a new uh and
deadly effect i believe the number
stands at something
on the order of 36 000 or 38 000
at last count lost in a single year to
crashes on the road uh we
cannot accept that and we need to move
toward a vision
uh where every trip uh is a safe one uh
whether it's long or short on any of
america's roadways
yeah and i just i want to put a fine
point on this one because you know the
department of transportation even our
local
transportation agencies tend to be the
departments of
cars and transportation is about however
you get around whether it's
on foot or uh via rail or
bicycle or bus or whatever i think it's
really critical that as
we reauthorize a
transportation bill and as
funding flows to local governments that
you
lead from the top to clarify that the
objective here
is to get people where they need to go
not to
always think in terms of widening the
aperture
through which the maximum number of cars
can move
at the maximum speed and i'd like you to
speak to that a little bit
yes you know when we were undertaking a
complete streets approach
in the city of south bend it meant a lot
of us to have uh
moral support from uh folks in in the
d.o.t under secretary foxx who
agreed with that vision and i think it's
very important that
we recognize the importance of roadways
where
pedestrians bicycles vehicles and any
other mode can
can coexist peacefully and that
completes
streets vision will continue to enjoy
support for me if confirmed
i just one final point about complete
streets and
um and safe routes to school and all the
rest of it i think we get a little bit
caught up in the jargon
people are dying in trying to get where
they need to go
and some of the vernacular here is
freaking people out and causing people
to move into their
uh partisan places uh and um
and everybody's either a pedestrian or a
car user or a transit user depending on
the day
and depending on the circumstances and
so pitting people against each other
depending on which mode
of transportation they're using i think
is the wrong approach
and i just like to start to change our
language
into being a little more plain about
making sure people don't die
uh going from where they live to where
they need to go
thank you very much thank you
okay i think we're going to we're going
to give uh some
senator sullivan has not just stepped in
the room we're going to let senator
markey go
thank you senator markey
can you hear me yes senator
okay oh beautiful thank you um welcome
mr secretary
um you will have my vote for this
uh for this very important position um
the fuel economy standards of our
country are central
uh to rolling back the amount of oil
which we consume
in our country and uh we saw
last year an actual reduction in fuel
economy standards
um even though there had been a
law promulgated by president obama
are working with the department of
transportation and the epa
to dramatically increase those fuel
economy standards up to 54 miles
per gallon by the year 2025.
um and we know that uh
70 of you know oil goes into uh
transportation in our society so
um my question to you is uh
in terms of the increase in fuel economy
standards uh it's a
a joint responsibility with the epa
the d.o.t has authority under nitsa
and a 2007 law which i
was the principal house author of which
uh donald trump uh which barack obama
used to increase those fuel economy
standards
um could you give us an outline of how
ambitious
you would you're planning on being in
terms of
increasing fuel economy standards and
then linking that to a plan to
have a mass deployment of electric
vehicles in
our country thank you senators as you
point out the transportation sector is
now
the biggest contributor of u.s sectors
to greenhouse gases
and when it comes to fuel economy and
what comes to improving the
climate profile of transportation i
believe we need to be moving
forward and not back this is not only
imperative in order for us to meet our
climate goals and prevent the
destruction of property and life
but it's also very important for
industry to have that kind of certainty
and clarity
american companies american workers
should be leading the way
in producing for example electric
vehicles and the most efficient vehicles
on the road
and we need to do everything we can to
support that as part of a partnership
with other agencies
in the administration as you point out
ev charging stations are a big part of
how we can do that and the president has
spoken to a goal of
deploying half a million electric
charging stations across the country
uh that's a a major lift but one i
believe we can meet
yeah thank you and again fuel economy
standards went
down last year after going up uh for
five consecutive years so it's a very
critical area um for us to be able to
deal with it's not a
it's not a technology issue it's just a
matter of political will to be able to
get that job done um the um
the issue of the
accountability of greenhouse gases
in any infrastructure project is going
to be important i've
uh introduced the green streets act
uh that would require that kind of
accounting could you talk a little bit
about what your plan is to
link greenhouse gas reductions to any
new infrastructure projects
well so much depends on making sure when
we talk about costs and benefits that
we're
truly accounting for those not only
environmental benefits but the cost
of business as usual so i'd look forward
to learning more about the the work that
you've cited and i think
it's going to be very important to
factor that in any time we're evaluating
projects and
opportunities going forward thank you
and i know the administration has
announced the new mask
initiative or planes for trains for
public transportation we need to protect
um passengers flight attendants anyone
that is a part of this of these
industries
um can you speak to that issue of the
need to
absolutely have more protections that
are put in place and
perhaps convening a joint task force of
aviation security and
public health experts to develop across
the board
of policies to uh provide that
protection during their payment
yes we are prepared to make sure that we
use all relevant authorities to
enforce the president's executive order
to ensure that across every mode of
transportation
workers passengers commuters are
protected and uh
i also uh want to say that i welcome
your push to make sure that we're
thinking across
uh different sectors departments with a
that whole of government approach
uh often these things are siloed but
obviously uh in order to deal with the
challenge this big
we need to be partnering across every
division of authority
uh in government to make sure everybody
in their lane is doing their part
yeah i also would love to work with you
on this rollback of
uh government authority to protect
against unfair and deceptive practices
in the consumer sector raising prices
for
uh air passengers for example just
tipping them upside down at the counter
we need to definitely take more action
in that era
area and love to work with you on that
issue
and also up on uh up on cape cod we have
the
the born and sagamore bridges um their
life expectancy has come to a conclusion
uh
and we're going to need help in and
not repairing them but replacing them in
the future so
i would love to invite you um mr
secretary to come up to cape cod so we
can give you a tour of the
born and sagamore bridges and uh maybe
help to create a plan for us to be able
to replace them before
uh their their usefulness has been
completely exhausted
i look forward to that visit and uh
would welcome the opportunity
thank you senator sullivan thank you
thank you madam chair mr mayor good to
see you again thanks for our meeting
yesterday i appreciated
the discussion you know i'm a big fan of
the
building trades men and women who build
infrastructure they're going to be an
important component of the constituency
for the department of transportation if
you're
confirmed and you will be also in charge
of themsa
with regard to pipelines uh you may have
seen mark mcmanus
who is the general president of the
united association of union
plumbers and pipefitters put out a
statement
yesterday about the president's decision
on keystone he said quote when built
with union labor
men and women of the united association
the building trades
with pipelines like keystone remain the
safest and most efficient modes of
energy transportation in the world
that's fems's
mission sadly the biden administration
has now put
thousands of union workers out of work
on day one how do you how do you respond
to
the men and women in the building trades
again i'm huge fans of them they built
this country
to comments like that day one the
president makes an announcement that put
thousands of union workers out of work
well like you i'm a big fan of the
building trades i take pride in the fact
that my very first campaign was run out
of the basement of the building trades
hall in in my hometown of south bend
the president of course has kept the
promise that he made to voters
when it's come to climate uh i believe
he will also
do you think that decision is going to
impact climate at all to kill the
keystone pipeline and kill thousands of
jobs
so i believe that the president's
climate vision will create
more jobs on that and i think it's going
to be very important to work with him
and work with congress to make sure that
we can deliver on that promise too
that on net more good-paying union jobs
will be created in the context of the
climate and infrastructure work that we
have before us
uh then uh has been impacted by other
decisions
so as we discussed yesterday i
appreciate your your comments on this
issue of
transportation equity it's a phrase i
hadn't really heard before but i think
it actually fits
my state quite well as you and i talked
about alaska
has 10 000 miles of roads indiana has 80
000 and yet we're 17 times bigger than
indiana so i think there's a little
transportation equity
inequity going on there so can i get
your commitment
to come up to my state if you're
confirmed to see
these real challenges as we talked about
yesterday every state's unique
but my state particularly on
infrastructure issues
is really unique or i like to say
resource rich
infrastructure poor can i get your
commitment uh you have it and i'm
looking forward to the visit
good um as i mentioned yesterday
mr mayor 82 of the
communities in my state are not
connected by roads
so that's pretty darn unique nobody else
no one else in america has
communities like that you already heard
here the
essential air service as we talked about
in alaska is really essential
some people go after this program
because maybe you don't need it in
plymouth or south bend
because you have a road connecting there
but in my communities
most of the time you don't have any
roads so essential air service
is very essential can i get your
commitment to have the department of
transportation in its budget
fully fund the eas especially for
communities that
really need it the communities that
don't have roads that connect to it i'll
certainly commit to working with you on
that and i i took the point as you've
educated me on this that
uh eas is important to a lot of
communities but there's a distinction
for those that
literally have no other connection thank
you um and similarly
we talked about uh commitments with
airport infrastructure and again i think
we all know that's important
in every community in my communities
there's a disparity
again transportation equity i would call
it transportation inequity
where in alaska where airports
are so important for these small
communities because there's no roads
we often have infrastructure that in the
lower 48
nobody mayors in particular would accept
can you work with me
in the faa administrator to make sure
upgrades come to my state's
airports because this isn't just
efficiency as you mentioned the most
important part of your job
is going to be safety and unfortunately
in alaska we have a very high
accident and even death rate with regard
to error
travel relative to the lower 48 can i
get your commitment if confirmed mr
mayor on that one too
yes look forward to working with you on
that okay and then finally
um we talked about this i think as a
mayor
you're going to have some good insights
but this really really important issue
of permitting reform
at the federal government level for
whatever reason
we have this permitting delays whether
it's on
highways whether it's on bridges i think
it takes
on average eight years to permit a
bridge in america
eight years we had a gold mine like i
said in alaska it's not you're not in
charge of gold mines
20 years to permit a gold mine
that now has that pays 400 people
very good wages what are your thoughts
on permitting reform nobody wants to cut
corners on safety in the environment
but eight years to permit a bridge we
had a hearing
the chairwoman probably remembers at the
seatac airport when it built
its new runway 15 years
to permit that new runway before they
even started
what are your thoughts on how we get to
more efficient
timely permitting that everybody in
america wants with the exception of a
few fringe groups
well as you uh correctly said as mayor
i've encountered
the ways in which these requirements can
can lengthen
or or complicate projects and i think
the key to approaching it
as you say is that there can't be any
cutting of corners around safety or
environmental goals the fundamental
reasons why
rules exist but anytime there's an
opportunity to meet those same goals
in a more streamlined fashion when there
are duplicated steps or
anything else that can be improved i'd
welcome an opportunity to work on that
great thank you thank you madam chair
senator peters
thank you madam chair and uh mayor but
good to see you here and uh
thank you uh for your willingness uh to
serve uh in this uh capacity
and i'm particularly pleased to see uh
jason here uh with you as well a partner
and
uh say among all of your great
accomplishments jasmine i appreciate
your a michigander
raised in the traverse city area worked
in the cherry groves of traverse city
and
uh and i know mayor that's a special
place for you too so it's great to have
both of you here before us and as both
of you know because you know the state
so well
michigan is the home of the auto
industry uh critically important to us
as well as
uh the the whole country and you have uh
publicly stated and i want to quote your
uh statement
automated vehicles can make
transportation safer
cleaner more accessible and more
efficient while creating thousands of
good jobs
and i certainly could not have agreed
more uh with uh that statement
uh so my question or uh to you uh mr
buddha judges
if confirmed as secretary will you
commit to working with
this committee and with me and senator
thune and others and uh
soon to be chair cantwell who has been
working with me on this
to help inform our legislation provided
for safe testing
as well as for the deployment of highly
automated vehicles
absolutely i'm enthusiastic about the
opportunity and for america to lead the
way
right excellent excellent the other area
that's important to the auto industry is
electric vehicles
uh and uh to me it's a it's certainly
it's a win-win proposition
for the united states automotive
industry to consumers and the
environment
and as you know more and more automakers
are increasing the number of evs
that they're producing in fact out of
our detroit automakers a whole long line
of very exciting evs are coming to the
market
currently and into the future president
biden has rightfully
prioritized electrification within the
transportation sector
and the federal fleet as part of his
climate platform which you
mentioned here earlier and that's
certainly an important priority for me
as well
if confirmed what steps will you take to
advance
electrification of the fleet including
potentially plans to
expand infrastructure along our
interstate highways
well i think to your point that the
infrastructure is key uh
industry is increasingly brill bringing
evs to the point where uh
they pencil out or represent a cost
savings uh
to a consumer and the more that's the
case
the more the real hesitation to
acquiring one will be range anxiety uh
worrying about whether you can get to
where you're going without having to
stop and charge
that's why the president's commitment to
half a million charging stations is so
important and i'm
looking forward to working with you to
try to deliver on that commitment
excellent
during our meeting last week when we did
a real deep dive into a lot of
these issues we discussed the importance
of femsa you've had some questions
related to that already during
the hearing uh and how important fimsa's
work is to
to keep our network of pipeline
infrastructure
safe and as secure as possible this has
been an extremely important
issue for me and it's been an important
issue for for all michiganders
given the fact that we have an aging oil
pipeline
line five that runs through michigan and
across
the streets of mackinac which uh as you
are well aware but for uh folks watching
it
kind of it's the straights between the
lower peninsula and the upper peninsula
an old 60 year old plus pipeline that
if there is a pipeline break there be
absolutely
catastrophic uh to this large body of
fresh water that provides drinking water
for 40 million people so having an oil
pipeline break there is catastrophic for
a variety of reasons
significant reasons uh so uh may i have
your commitment
uh that if confirmed that you'll
continue a very close collaboration i've
been able to have with
uh femsa as uh relates to
line five and the federal government
particularly until we get a final
determination right now there's
uh talk between the state and the
pipeline company in federal but we need
to have a very close
cooperative relationship with fimsa and
i hope you would make that
a priority if confirmed yes i'm
committed to that cooperation and i know
how important it is
right and uh the other issue related to
fimsa uh
is will you ensure that the agency has
the adequate resources needed
to recruit and retain uh personnel
that's a challenge across the federal
enterprise but certainly an issue with
with themselves that we need to address
and
certainly welcome the opportunity to
work with you if confirmed i would too
great well thank you madam chair i yield
thank you uh senator peters and we
definitely want to work with you on the
electric vehicle legislation and
certainly appreciate your leadership on
that and understand how important it is
on so many fronts so thank you for
everything you've been doing to advance
that legislation i know you've been
working with senator thune
uh for some time on that so look forward
to
working with you um next on the list is
senator blackburn
if if now is a good yes okay
thank you we were uh over in sask
uh just across the hall about
uh trying to move forward with general
austin
so um apologize but thank you
for your time today and have been able
to monitor
remotely the hearing and listen
to uh some of your responses
to questions and thank you also for
your time uh prior to this
to talk through some of the things so
let's pick up where we left off
yesterday
uh talking about your work as a mayor
and looking through
some of the appointees i think you're
the only
mayor that would be our previous mayor
that would be
in the president's cabinet myself and
mayor walsh of boston for uh
okay well thank you for that correction
but as we said yesterday
you understand how red tape is
very expensive for local governments
and as i told you with tennesseans and
my tennessee county mayors
and city mayors it is the red tape
that many times causes them to set aside
a transportation project simply because
nepa studies time
expense and it
makes transportation less efficient
because of some of these regulations in
the red tape that is attached to that
so i would hope that and i would like
for you to talk about
what you would bring to the table
to help the department of transportation
be more efficient and less cumbersome
when it comes to federal regulations the
impact and the cost
thank you senator for the question and
it does rhyme with with my experience uh
as a mayor eager to get things done and
encountering a lot of
regulatory complexity and so i think the
the
approach to that begins with listening
uh speaking actively
with uh those local leaders state local
tribal and territorial leaders trying to
get things done
as well as an open door to to you and
other congressional colleagues who can
uh really flag some of these issues and
anytime there's an opportunity to be
more user-friendly or more streamlined
without compromising of course
on the safety environmental or other
goals that are at stake
i'd welcome ways to do that i think it
is important
that we put a focus on doing that
also i know you've talked some about ev
production
just to highlight with you that the
state of tennessee has a lead
in some of this production with some of
our auto manufacturers
so we are going to be watching carefully
as you and the department of
transportation
make any moves that are going to deal
with the evs and
their production models one other thing
that i want to highlight
with you and see if you have any further
additional information
we talked about the two billion dollars
in the cares act
that is there for motor coaches
buses flagged vessels
and the need for treasury to move
forward
on the rules and also dispensing
those at dollars would you like to make
some comments there
yes as you pointed out these are dollars
that uh you know many including in your
state are relying on
and uh i'm looking into what steps might
need to be taken
uh partnering with treasury to make sure
that they get out the door efficiently
well we need action on this item
uh the motor coach industry as we
discussed yesterday
they are functioning at less than
10 percent of the capacity
for where they were in 2019.
this is truly a dire situation as we
mentioned yesterday
they were the first to be shut down they
are going to be
among the last to open back up
and this has happened to them through no
fault of their
own and it is going to be imperative
that there be a a response
to them sooner rather than later
understood thank you uh i yield back
thank you i think next is senator
baldwin remotely
thank you madam chair um and uh
to mayor buddage uh congratulations on
your nomination
welcome to the commerce science
transportation committee
um and i can't let uh
senator peters uh be alone in connecting
with our states not only
is chaston a native
michigander but attended the university
of wisconsin at eau claire uh
and so uh we welcome this sort of
upper midwestern uh uh tradition
uh i wanted to just start by noting that
our states uh share uh
a deep uh tradition and history of
manufacturing
and i have always believed that when
we're expending
taxpayer dollars we ought to be
supporting
american workers american products
and american ingenuity and research and
development
and obviously the department of
transportation plays an enormous role
in furthering those opportunities
i know that my colleagues and i on the
commerce science and transportation
committee
are so eager to work on infrastructure
and really believe that we'll seize the
opportunity to build
modern sustainable infrastructure
while supporting american workers so let
me begin with a couple of brief yes or
no questions
will you commit to including buy america
requirements
in any biden administration
infrastructure proposal
to ensure that federal funding supports
products that are made in america
yes i strongly support you or i join you
in strongly supporting buy america
okay and will you commit to supporting
legislation that would
close existing gaps and loopholes in law
that allow taxpayer funds to
purchase products not made in america i
would look forward to working with you
on that i know that
there are a lot of questions about some
of these exceptions that have emerged
yes let me provide one example
i am the co-author of bipartisan
legislation that prevents
the federal transit administration
grants
from going to chinese state-owned or
subsidized companies
in the last administration contrary to
congressional intent they provided a
permanent exemption exemption to transit
agencies
currently working with these chinese
state subsidized
or state-owned companies will you commit
to honor the congressional intent
and remove permanent exemptions provided
to chinese companies by
the trump federal transit administration
so
this is something i'll uh look into
right away because i know it's very
important to meet the congressional
well i appreciate that um
as transportation secretary you will be
charged with
enforcing the existing buy america rules
and laws
back in 1978 congress
passed legislation requiring all
manufactured
products to be subjected by america
rules
since 1978 the department of
transportation
has provided blanket waivers for the
purchase of manufactured products
made outside of the united states i'm
wondering if you will commit to removing
this waiver or restricting it
in order to require certain frequently
purchased products be made in america
for example
traffic lights highway signs and traffic
cones to name just a few
so uh the goal is to make sure as much
as possible this is made in america and
if confirmed
i do commit to looking at what we can do
to adjust
or change or or perhaps uh
rescind that that provision well
thank you very much uh that concludes my
questions but i am
very much looking forward to working you
with you during your
uh tenure as secretary of transportation
likewise thank you
uh thank you very much senator baldwin
senator
scott is next i believe
thanks mayor thanks thanks for your
services mayor and thanks for um
willingness to serve and we had a good
conversation the other day so um
thanks for uh being as direct as you
could um first
as you know um the highway trust fund it
doesn't have enough funding or it's
going to insolvent
would would you support gas tax
increases
and if so how much so i think all
options need to be on the table
as you know the the gas tax has not been
increased since 1993 and it's never been
pegged to inflation and that's one of
the reasons why
the current state of the highway trust
fund is that there's more going out than
coming in
up until now that's been addressed with
tran general
funding transfers i don't know whether
congress would want to continue doing
that
and i think in the near term we need a
solution
that can provide some predictability and
sustainability in the long term we need
to bear in mind also that as vehicles
become more efficient
as we pursue electrification sooner or
later
there will be questions about whether
the gas tax can be effective at all
so do you have you looked at you know
i'll option be on table what would you
what would you propose to pay for it
well
there are several different models again
in the short to medium term that could
include
revisiting the gas tax adjusting it and
or connecting it to inflation
right now it's also assessed as you know
in a dollars and cents level not
not on a percentage basis uh of course
the way we've been filling the gaps so
far has been general fund transfers
that could continue if there's appetite
for it
a lot has been uh suggested recently
about the idea of vehicle miles travel
based so if
if we're committed to the idea of user
pays then part of how you might do that
would be
based on vehicle miles traveled but that
raises of course
concerns about privacy and there remains
some technological questions too
these are examples of some of the things
that could be part of the solution but i
know that that's going to have to be a
conversation
not only in the administration but but
with congress too
so i spent i just finished i've been up
here a couple years i just finished
eight years as governor and you know
we were able to invest quite a bit of
money in the environment but only
because we dramatically grew our economy
because without
a good economy there's no there's no
money in the budget um to uh to do that
you've in the past supported the green
new deal um
what what um what would you be
interested
impact our businesses and our families
so uh the president's been clear about
the importance of dealing with
climate change and ensuring that we do
our part to prevent the destruction of
property and the destruction of life
and this is our chance i believe if we
get this right this will also be
something that enhances
economic opportunity
electric vehicles uh seeing america
become
uh a lead or continue to be a leader
and generate kind of economic
opportunity for american workers
that's involved in that expanding market
whether we're talking about charging
infrastructure
support for that emerging industry or
other modes of transportation
that are becoming greener or at least
ought to become greener
that's my idea of a green deal that
everybody
could get behind because it will leave
us economically better off
as well as meeting the climate crisis
before it's too late
the um there was one study that said the
green new deal will cost
what almost 100 trillion dollars so
how you know what will impact if if we
did something like that what impact
would that
have on on our economy and jobs and
of our businesses that are competing
globally so are you referring to the
president's climate proposal or
no the green the one that was proposed
in the everybody talked about during the
presidential race
okay so i proposed uh one i'm not sure
that it was scored in that way uh of
course the
the president won our primary and the
election and uh that'll be the vision
that goes forward
um and ultimately we cannot afford not
to act
on climate as as you know and the the
question becomes how can we do that in a
way that
uh creates economic benefit in the near
term as well as
preventing catastrophe in the long term
the president's proposed taking some
money out of the
out of fema uh that would that's
normally used for disaster such as it
might say hurricanes or
in your state would be flooding possibly
maybe even wildfires we have some in
florida
and it's talked about taking two billion
dollars and giving it to new york
and to new york city um to deal with
their budgets as a result of coven
um i've had a concern about that
supposed to be used for disasters is do
you see any influence
any way that d.o.t would be doing the
same sort of thing which takes some of
your budget to
help a particular state over their
budget issues rather than
um for the purpose that the money was
allocated for
well certainly uh uh we need to make
sure that anything is spent in a way
that meets congressional attention
intent
uh i do think that uh part of the
concept of rescue
uh is sometimes to intervene when uh
there's a danger of
uh anything from a transit agency not
being able to make service
to some other kind of impact on critical
services or state and local government
uh but i do think that that has to be
done in a way that's consistent with the
specific intent
that that funding was laid aside for
thank you thank you mr chairman thank
you senator
scott senator duckworth
thank you mr chairman and thank you
madam chair as well uh secretary
designate what he did
i met i want to congratulate you your
husband chaston and the rest of your
family
on this historic nomination i believe
that your appointment is precisely what
president biden had in mind when he
expressed the desire to serve as a
bridge
to the next generation of leaders you
served our nation in uniform
you've led your local community and now
you've been called to on to help lead
the biden administration's effort
to rebuild our country's roads bridges
transit systems rail airports and
waterways
all of which combined have been raided
by the american association of civil
engineers that is
at a d minus grade since i have about
five hours worth of material that i'd
love to discuss
but only five minutes i'm going to
devote my questions to addressing two
vital priorities that should serve as
the north stars for your department
first local job creation and second
achieving infrastructure for all one of
my top priorities is making sure that
infrastructure investment
drives local job creation i think this
is as
relevant as this area the department
doesn't need to wait on
congress to act under europe potential
leadership the department could take
action
to propose a new rule that strengthens
local economies in illinois and
throughout the country
furthermore enhancing local hiring
efforts should attract bipartisan
support
since solving the problem requires
eliminating or dramatically overhauling
a 20
a 34-year-old regulation that is
bureaucratic
antiquated and worst of all harmful to
local job creation based on my own
experience repealing an
ineffective one-size-fits-all regulation
may be one of the most productive first
steps for a new administration
the very first bill i succeeded in
getting signed into law as a senator was
a straightforward repeal of a regulation
that was well
intentioned but ultimately unworkable
for local metropolitan planning
organizations
mr mayor i would be happy to work with
you on a similar effort
we should empower local mayors city
councils indeed any recipient of federal
funds to implement job creation programs
that promote hiring local residents to
get work to get to work rebuilding the
very communities they live in
mayor beatrice will you work with me to
eliminate this
anti-growth regulation and replace with
a modern mood that actively encourages
infrastructure projects
to hire local workers thank you senator
i look forward to
working with you on this we need to make
sure that we're doing everything we can
to support
local economic growth and i recognize
that
it's been a long time since those local
higher provisions were written and
there's
an opportunity to bring them up to speed
thank you now i want to turn to another
issue of critical importance making sure
that transportation systems funded by
all americans
are actually capable of serving all
americans you know i'm not one to mince
words so just be frank the
transportation community has failed the
disability community
over and over again from amtrak
squandering the incredibly generous
implementation timeline under the
americans with disabilities act
to airlines making travel more difficult
for people who require
service animals to transit systems often
failing to keep elevators working
the disability community has been left
stranded far too often and for far
too long for example your very
predecessor made clear where she stood
on disability rights
when one of her first actions as
secretary was eliminating a consumer
protection rule that
simply provided the flying public with
transparency on each carrier's record in
transporting and damaging wheelchairs
while we were able to undo this damage
with the legislative fix
i remained deeply frustrated that an act
of congress was even
required to do so many rightfully view
the callous way that carriers handle
wheelchairs along with the hands-off
approach adopted by regulators
as a prime example of the harmful
ableist attitudes that are
far too pervasive in our society
including in the transportation sector
first will you work with my office to
help refine and improve my forthcoming
all
stations accessibility program act which
would establish a competitive grant
program
to help outdated transportation
facilities and rolling stock comply with
the ada
yes i'm eager to work with you on this
it's so important that our transit and
transportation
resources are accessible
thank you and then second i strongly
urge you to expand your senior
leadership team
to include a dedicated advisor with
experience and expertise on
accessibility and universal design
i'd be very open to that
you do that thank you you know
accessibility must be
a con considered at the forefront of all
policy
development rather than treat it like an
afterthought or a box checking exercise
we really need strong leadership from
you and others in administration
my own home state of illinois in chicago
our
mass transit system the l is projected
to be
fully uh wheelchair accessible in 20
years which would make it a half century
since the passage of the ada
and i'm sure that is the case all over
the country we can't let that be the
standard
um with that i yield back thank you
thank you
thank you very much senator duckworth
senator lee
thank you very much uh for being here mr
butterjudge it's a
pleasure to have you and i wanted to
follow up i want to start by following
up on
some questions that were asked to you by
senator scott
um would you agree with me
if i said that we've sort of over
extended ourselves ourselves
with regard to the highway trust fund in
other words we're
when we created the highway trust fund
the whole idea is we would impose this
gasoline tax
in order to create an interstate highway
system over time
we were going to hand that system over
to the states to maintain
and then we'd step back and eventually
get rid of it we haven't done it that
way we've used it to maintain
the federal highway system which is
understandable but then we've added to
the list of things that we fund
using the highway trust fund and we've
had to dip over and over again into the
general fund in order to
meet our basic needs so
i believe when senator scott raised a
similar question your response was
you you'd consider anything on the table
all options should be on the table is
that right
yes i think uh there's a recognition
that we don't have adequate national
resources going into
roads and highways and that we need to
look at any responsible viable revenue
mechanism we can all agree on to do
something about that
could that conclude include possibly
increasing the gasoline tax well it's
possible certain uh
certainly many states have taken that
step and including my own but it's not
the only approach
i have worried it is my own state has it
aggressive tax uh one that
disproportionately
uh uh affects poor americans would you
agree with that
certainly one of the concerns about the
gas tax is it's likely not as
progressive as uh
federal income tax for example right
right not just not as progressive
but it does have a regressive impact
so in light of that um it's my that we
have to be
looking at a lot of other options um
before or or instead of getting to that
one um
what about cost savings measures are
there things you'd
be willing to consider on that front
well certainly something i want to look
into right away i've confirmed
any uh government enterprise needs to
run as efficiently as possible these are
taxpayer dollars and we've got to make
sure that uh we are
are streamlined in delivering as as much
as possible toward the actual
intent it was a focus of mine uh when i
was mayor make sure that we
didn't have any duplicative or outdated
things that were adding to the cost of
delivery and that's certainly something
i want to look into here as well
is it so possible that some of the
funding that we provide for the states
for their um transportation
infrastructure projects
could be made more efficient and more
effective
by reducing some of the regulatory
burden that goes with them
uh i've heard from some state
transportation officials that
20 to 30 in some cases they insist it's
more than that of a particular project
uh can be attributed to compliance
uh with the federal regulations that go
with the receipt of federal money
is that something we ought to look at
certainly want to take a look at this
you know
again as mayor i saw how rules and
regulations can
add to the time or expense of a project
of course those rules are there for a
reason but if we can meet that same
reason
with less of a burden we should look at
how to do it i'd also like to talk to
you about drones for a minute
um drones are
becoming a you know a very new
tool and a significant driving force in
our economy drone technology has the
ability to improve
the lives of of every american in one
way or another
um there are many who are concerned
about the
impact that um a regulatory system could
have on them
one way or another there are some within
the federal government who have wanted
the federal government
to be the actor
the enforcer um the the essentially the
exclusive regulatory body
uh treating them much the same way that
we tr that we treat
uh airlines uh for instance
and yet i think it's important that we
look at key differences between
drones and airliners drones in many
instances
are operating just feet
sometimes inches above the ground
they're much more intrusive they have a
much more direct impact
on property rights because instead of
dealing with
tens of thousands of feet in their
normal operating elevation we're talking
about feet or inches
at most you know a couple hundred feet
it's my view that we need to leave room
for
state interests it's states that
determine
um nuisance law at states that determine
property rights and where someone's
property rights end
and begin and how they're impacted by
nuisance law and things like that would
you agree
that the states have an important
prominent role to play
one that we need to make sure isn't
completely preempted by the federal
authority that might exist here i think
he raised a really important point i
think up until
now most of the regulatory concern has
been on the faa side just thinking about
uh
the fact that drones entered the
national airspace but the smaller it is
and the nearer it is to the earth the
less it has in common with those
aircraft and
i recognize that that kind of safety
framework for the national airspace
isn't really relevant to the question of
maybe a drone going a few feet up
being over a neighbor's fence which
might very well call for
some kind of response but not
necessarily a federal aviation safety
response
thank you senator lee thank you um
senator tester do you have any questions
at all i do mr chairman
i want to tell you that this is my first
committee back
since the pandemic i've been in some
executive sessions
the first one back and i just want to
say thank you to the staff i mean this
is
a hell of an operation and and i just
want to thank uh
thank you the ranking member and the
staff for being able to pull this off
and welcome mayor pete
your intellect has preceded you into the
room
and i'm going to tell you that i have
been able to watch nearly every question
and watch your answers
you have put on a clinic on how
a nominee should work
and act you haven't avoided the
questions you've been straightforward
and you know what the hell you're
talking about and that's really
pretty damn refreshing and and i just
want to thank you
uh for being here as as we talked and
thank you for the virtual meeting we had
a few days ago
uh but as we talked infrastructure in
rural america is as important as it is
anywhere in the country
and making sure that rural america has
access to the dollars even though we
don't have as many people for square
mile
is critically important let me give you
an example there's a little highway that
runs south of my farm
it's about 20 miles long it was built
when i was in grade school and then
extended out when i was in high school
that little highway saves every farmer
that lives out in my community
literally hundreds if not thousands of
dollars every year
why less flat tires front ends aren't
knocked out of a line less wear and tear
on vehicles
so you can run them longer that is why
we need to make sure rural america is
taken care of i don't pay
enough gas tax to fund a project that
would put that highway in
but the truth is all working together as
americans
with the gas tax fund we've done it i
appreciate your answers
on the on on the highway trust fund
i do think we need to look at different
ways to to do it
to fund it i don't think what we've got
now i don't think anybody on this
committee thinks it's sustainable or not
it's not and so we've got to figure out
how to do it because infrastructure is
important as i've said before we're
living off of the infrastructure
investment of my parents and
grandparents and
quite frankly that's unacceptable we owe
more to our kids than that
and we shouldn't be doing it on borrowed
money we should be doing it we should be
paying for it
and so i want to i want to i want to
thank you for your answers on
on those things i i do want to uh
talk about something that has been
brought up before by different
questioners and that is the
uh that is uh the one size fits all
on on regulations
it is really important that you take
into account flexibility
i've delayed electronic logging devices
for livestock haulers because i think
those rigs will put people out of
business and quite frankly
not only in the trucking business but in
agriculture
and people have to understand that if
you've you've got a pot load cattle or
hogs
you just can't pull over on the side of
the road because if you do
it's going to overheat they're going to
die they have to have that air going
through
that that pot and as
senator fisher said if you unload them
if you've ever loaded cattle or hogs
it's tough enough to do the first time
you try to do it the second time and i
don't want to be around i'll just tell
you
because it's a hell of a job and so make
sure there's that flexibility there and
as senator
blunt brought up the importance of a
patchwork approach
to trucking regulations specifically
with the california meal and rest break
issue
i just want to echo what senator once
said on that
and then to get back to where senator
thune was
on rural america and tribal areas
how if you're confirmed how will you
prioritize that
well i think it's very important that
rural and tribal communities have
every opportunity to benefit from what i
expect will be
increased infrastructure investment we
hope partnering with congress
in the coming year so how do we do that
we make sure there are criteria
that are fair that give every kind of
community a fair shake especially
when we're talking about these kinds of
discretionary programs
secondly i think we need to communicate
very clearly uh how to engage and make
that
process as simple as possible
recognizing that the smaller a community
is the less you can
assume that they'll have a lot of
personnel on this uh third i believe
there are cases where technical
assistance would be
justified as well to help ease that
process along for communities that might
not have those resources
thank you i want to talk about air
travel for just a second because it is
critically important when it comes to
economic development if you come from a
state
like montana there's not a lot of
competition and now since covet 19's
come down the pipe
we don't have a lot of flights either
and rightfully so i'm not being critical
if the flights are empty it's pretty
tough to
maintain them um although we've we've
helped the airlines significantly
in congress but my question revolves
around once things get back to normal
and assuming
those flights come back
competition isn't we've got a couple
airlines truthfully and
and some of the airports have three
airlines but
uh yeah three maybe four okay but it's
not it's not a competitive marketplace
because we're a rural state
and so is there anything you think you
could do as secretary of transportation
to encourage more competition
in the airline industry overall well i
know that
uh there are responsibilities and
authorities pertaining to the
competitiveness
of the airline industry and i'm looking
forward to getting a better
understanding about how to mobilize them
in this way
because i do think it's it's very
important that communities of every size
have that kind of competition and
support i can tell you when we were
able to uh see another major carrier
added to
a south bend international airport which
is small but mighty
uh made a big difference across the
board yeah absolutely i i'll just close
with this thank you for being here
thanks for putting your name in
and the hopper to be secretary of
transportation
and uh for all the other nominees that
are out there you need to look at what's
happened in the last two hours
you've you've you've done a nice job
answering questions and i thank you for
that
thank you very much senator tester
senator cruz
thank you mr chairman uh mr butterjet
congratulations
on your nomination thank you um
the department of transportation has
responsibility for infrastructure
has a major role concerning jobs
and has responsibility for ensuring
safety
i am hopeful that if you're confirmed
your tenure we will see material
advances
on all three i will say it was
disconcerting to see yesterday the first
day of the biden administration
straight out of the gate president biden
announced that he was canceling the
keystone pipeline
that is a major infrastructure project
that is a project that right now today
has 200 good paying union jobs
and in 2021 the keystone pipeline
was scheduled to have more than 11 000
jobs including 8
000 union jobs for contracts worth 1.6
billion dollars
and with the stroke of a pen president
biden has told
those 11 000 workers those union workers
your jobs are gone
mr buda judge what do you say to those
workers whose jobs have just been
eliminated by presidential edict well i
think the most
important thing is to make sure that we
make good on the promise of the
president's climate vision as being one
that on net
creates far more jobs millions we hope i
know that won't just happen
we'll have to do a lot of work to make
sure that's real but getting this right
means ensuring that there are more good
paying union jobs for
all americans delivered through that
infrastructure vision
so for those workers the answer is
somebody else will get a job
the answer is that we are very eager to
see those workers continue to be
employed in
good paying union jobs even if they
might be different ones
well i i fear that decision is the front
end of a whole series of regulatory
decisions one after the other
after the other that will be eliminating
union jobs that will be eliminating
manufacturing jobs that will be
eliminating
energy jobs and that
is all together out of step with what
the american people want
there is also some rich irony in the
long history of the democratic party
there was a time
when the democratic party under
presidents like fdr
was considered the party of union
workers of blue-collar workers and
decisions like yesterday and
and i fear more decisions that we will
see in the days and weeks to come
are demonstrating more and more that
today's democratic party is not
concerned with working men and women
having jobs
and that the answer is we'll eliminate
your jobs
and i guess good luck in the future
well again senator i think the answer is
that we're going to create
more good paying union jobs and we can
do that
while recognizing the fact that when the
books are written about our careers one
of the main things we'll be judged on
is whether we did enough to stop the
destruction of life
and property due to climate change i've
got to believe we can do both of those
things but if you and i can make
common cause in our support for labor
then i think that's great news
all right well when it comes to
addressing climate change
uh in the last year the united states
was the number one nation on the face of
the planet
for reduction of carbon emissions
the major driver of that has been the
shift from
coal-fired electricity production
to natural gas and the gas renaissance
we're seeing in this country
is producing enormous environmental
benefits
now this past june
the pipeline and hazardous materials
safety administration
finalized a rule authorizing the bulk
transportation
of liquefied natural gas by rail
lng by rail gives americans particularly
those who are limited with energy
choices because of geography
gives them an affordable option for
electricity
what are your views on the rule that was
finalized allowing the the
transportation of lng by rail
so that's something i want to take a
closer look at if confirmed
i believe it's very important that we
take
account of the safety considerations
that are at stake
i do recognize that natural gas
certainly for climate purposes
is not the same thing as coal uh in our
own city in our own municipal fleet
we did a lot of work on things from
garbage trucks to light duty vehicles
to have some of them run on gas and i
think there was federal support to do
that on our
bus system as well it's not the same as
coal but of course it's also not the
same as hydroelectric power
and we need to be balancing all these
considerations as we go forward
so you're saying if confirmed you would
consider
repealing that rule and stopping the
transportation of lng by rail
the best honest answer i give you now is
that i'll be taking a hard look at it
well that's disconcerting as well let's
let's shift to a different topic as my
final question
as you know roughly three-fourths of
d-o-t's budget is mandatory budget
authority
derived from the highway trust fund uh
based on 2020 apportionment only three
states in the country
texas colorado and south carolina remain
donor states
meaning they contribute more than they
receive back
in the apportionment the state of texas
contributes contributed 212 million
dollars
more to the highway trust fund than the
state's roads received
senator from your state senator donnelly
had introduced legislation that would
adjust that formula so that states
would not be losers would not be donor
states are you supportive of reassessing
that for me
well i'll make sure to call senator
donnelly his good friend and learn more
about that action and
we'll take a look at that as well if
confirmed thank you thank you senator
cruz
senator cinema oh thank you mr chairman
i appreciate mr buddha judge joining us
today arizona is one of the fastest
growing states in the nation
and my state's steady increase in
population jobs and opportunities
puts additional stress on our
transportation infrastructure including
our highways
bridges airports trains and buses we
need to work cooperatively to develop
transportation options that work for all
arizona communities
from our largest cities to our rural and
tribal areas
and now is the time to develop
bipartisan solutions to invest in
arizona
and build the infrastructure we need to
continue to grow and succeed
if you were confirmed for this important
role i look forward to working with you
to improve and expand the transportation
infrastructure
in arizona create good paying jobs and
utilize new technologies
to lay the foundation for sustainable
growth in all parts of my state
now my top priority for the last year
has been working with local state and
federal partners
to keep arizonans healthy and safe from
the pandemic
as the ranking member on the aviation
subcommittee and someone who has to fly
regularly i called on the previous
administration to do more to improve
coveted safety throughout the
transportation system including on
airlines and in airports
yesterday the president issued a mass
mandate and called for americans to help
prevent transmission of the virus
what are your plans to address covet
transportation safety
if confirmed well i think that uh
step one is to make sure that we are
effectively carrying out the president's
directive and that means
using all of the available authorities
to
implement those mass mandates on
especially when it comes to aviation
and interstate travel where direct
authorities don't exist we'll want to
make sure that we're supporting
for example local transit agencies and
those organizations that have sometimes
been left to
develop their own protocols and support
them as well in implementing mass
mandates and anything needed in order to
prevent the spread of the disease
well thank you as you know arizona needs
additional transportation infrastructure
to support the growth throughout our
state
one major project for arizona is
interstate 11
which will run from the mexican border
to phoenix through las vegas to northern
nevada
it will be an important leak between two
of the largest cities in the
country it'll increase regional trade
and commerce with mexico and canada
and it will relieve congestion and air
pollution in downtown phoenix
so i'm asking for your commitment to
learn about this important project for
the southwest and work with me to
advance the i-11 if confirmed
i do look forward to learning more about
uh the i-11 project and uh uh
have uh heard from you and uh others in
your region about how important this
is economically and for the future of
your states
i appreciate that you know the phoenix
metro's area's continued economic and
population growth means that the
region's public transit system must grow
as well
we're the fifth largest city in the
country but our public transportation
infrastructure
lags behind many similarly sized cities
last year
valley metro's light rail received a
federal transit administration grant
to build out the south central extension
which will allow many lower income
arizonans to
more easily travel downtown to arizona
state university and to sky harbor
airport
there's another valley metro light rail
project
under review at the department which is
the northwest extension phase 2.
it's a project that will extend public
transit to growing neighborhoods north
west of downtown so i ask again for your
commitment to learn about this project
and work with me to advance transit
projects across the state
that will allow for arizona's
sustainable growth absolutely i look
forward to it
thanks in the short time we have
remaining i want to talk about the 22
native american tribes in arizona
each of our tribes has very specific and
unique transportation needs
and i want to highlight the tribal
transportation program
it's part of the federal highway
administration it works to address the
transportation needs of tribal
governments and as you know
better transportation options contribute
to the economic development tribal
communities
last year i worked with my republican
colleague on this committee senator
thune to develop bipartisan legislation
that bolsters the tribal transportation
program
and provides flexibility for tribes in
arizona and i'm looking forward to
continuing that work with senator thune
and with you
in your new position so i'd ask you to
just pay attention to this project
and work with senator thune and i as we
support tribal communities throughout
arizona and the country
i will very important to build up a
the right kind of visibility and
connectivity with the
tribal nations and i'd welcome the
chance to work with you on that as well
thank you so much mr chairman i yield
back and i thank mr bitter judge for
being here today
thank you very much senator cinema
senator capito
thank you mr chair uh thank you for
uh mr buddha judge for being before the
committee today and thank you for the
phone call that we shared
i think several weeks ago i really
appreciate that
um as you know i also i serve on
commerce but i also serve on the epw
committee which has
quite a bit of uh jurisdiction in terms
of transportation
last year we were able to uh in the last
congress have a bipartisan
america's transportation infrastructure
act we call it a tia
we had i think a good compromise between
republicans and democrat
uh asks and wants and uh we were able to
win uh the entire uh epw committee uh
both republicans and democrats
and unanimous consent for the spill but
unfortunately we were unable to get it
across the line um i i guess what i'm
i'm certain that you've probably given
this earlier today and i haven't uh
seen it but i uh i would like to ask for
your commitment that it confirmed you'll
work with me and others
to craft a re-operation reauthorization
bill that does satisfy
both sides of the aisle and both parties
in both chambers
yes let me say i admire the bipartisan
character of the pw bill and i'm looking
forward to uh
learning more about that and building on
it as we move forward
well great thank you i think that's
going to be something we're going to be
under a time frame and as
as you've probably already figured out
here in washington deadlines are good uh
if we stick to them
and we're known for not sticking to some
of them at times so let's stick to this
one i think
it's the certainty of having the funding
sources in play and the priorities in
play
certainly helps all of our states in
terms of commitments and
moving projects forward so i look
forward to that uh in october of 2020
virgin hyperloop announced the selection
of west virginia
uh and we were elated uh as the new home
for their hyperloop
certification center it's an exciting
new mode of transportation it has the
potential to transform
the way americans travel it's a
high-speed rail
but this new mode of transportation
continue as it continuing to develop
it's sort of falling in between the
different regulatory uh environments and
we want to make sure that we are
balancing innovation with ensuring
passenger safety but also being able to
move this
along i think it's going to be critical
for our future so
would you commit to working with me to
build on the work that has already been
done
uh to examine the proper regulatory
framework for emerging technologies like
hyperloop and i'm wondering if you have
any perspective on that
and other emerging technologies thank
you yes this uh
reminds me of some of what we were
discussing earlier when it comes to
automated vehicles and hyperloop is
another example where
technology is being developed industry
is advancing and we have to make sure
the regulatory framework
keeps up both that it keeps up in terms
of securing our safety and other goals
and that uh it keeps up in terms of
making sure that uh
these new technologies can can flourish
in a safe way and so i'm eager to work
with you on making sure that we do that
knowing all of the emerging technologies
that are set to mature in the 2020s
well uh secretary chao during her
stewardship uh
created uh with the help of of congress
a a regulatory framework sort of
so that people who are uh virgin
hyperloop and
others have a place to go to find out
the answer so i look forward to
working with you in that entity to make
sure that uh
we're moving that along i'm i'm not
going to ask you about how you're going
to pay
the transportation bill because if you
had an answer for that um
and all of us did there's a lot of ideas
out there but
it's not as easy as we all make it sound
is it i don't think so so i'm going to
skip that one because i'm certain that
you've been
asked about that i do want to talk about
something else i mentioned to you which
is the completion
of the appalachian highway development
system that was conceived in the 60s
to open up appalachia there is one very
uh important project remaining in that
important to my state order
quarter h it's moving towards completion
but it's still pretty rugged territory
and we need to have that commitment so
i would like to ask you to to work with
me to continue this commitment
to see the completion of quarter h
as it moves through the as the last
phase of the appalachian development
highway system
so any comments you might want to make
there i certainly want to
learn more about this uh uh this
important initiative and uh yes uh i
recall you raising this in our
prior conversation and uh would welcome
a chance to work with you on this
well uh when we complete it together
we'll we'll ride those hills
uh uh through the beautiful venues and
sceneries of west virginia because
it's gonna be uh it's really gonna open
up a part of our state
uh that will be able to benefit not just
from tourism but economic development
and other things and after all that's
what transportation corridors
uh are for and and so along with safety
i'm very very excited about it but
thank you for being here congratulations
on your um
nomination and i look forward to seeing
uh
seeing the next steps thank you thank
you very much senator capito
senator rosen thank you mr chairman
and uh mr buddhich thank you for being
with us today
for your commitment to serving our
nation i really appreciated our very
productive uh
meeting i look forward to learning more
about your plans to
invest in our nation's infrastructure
support
nevada's travel and tourism uh economy
and create all those new transportation
infrastructure jobs that we need
and you know admits a global pandemic
that has really devastated our economy
i really urge this committee to
facilitate a swift confirmation of mr
buda judge so that he can immediately
get to work on all the things that our
colleagues on this committee
have asked for for our nation and their
states as well
i want to build a little bit of just
briefly make could comment on what
senator sinema said about i-11 of course
nevada and arizona
we are the uh both fast-growing states
out west and we are not connected
between las vegas and phoenix
our infrastructure just hasn't kept up
with that explosive growth
so we need significant transportation
investments our new highway
infrastructure
not just to prepare the old highways and
that
investment must include a new interstate
11
that runs from the mexican border
through phoenix and through las vegas
up through the northern half of my state
it is extremely important
this remains one of the top
infrastructure priorities and i think
it's one of the few remaining
metropolitan areas that aren't connected
directly by interstate so i appreciate
that you made a commitment to senator
cinema on that and we'll look to get
work together with the
arizona delegation and you could do that
but i want to build also on
aviation travel and tourism
nevada travel and tourism of course are
the lifeblood of our economy
our airports well they're the gateway to
our great state
millions of domestic international
tourists
and business travelers and in 2019 alone
uh just one of our airports saw over 50
million passengers generated 35 billion
in economic output
supported over 250 000 jobs
and was responsible of 18 of our
region's gross domestic
product that's why economic slowdown has
been so devastating
and so the travel slowed down of course
it's meant job losses
not only at our amazing hotels and
casinos our convention halls but at the
airports themselves from gate agents
concessionaires all the related small
businesses that support
all of that and uh in order to
fully recover from the pandemic we have
to work
on economic growth and invest in our
aviation airports and tourism generally
so i'm hoping that you'll commit to
working with me
to ensure that biden uh the biden
administration's infrastructure package
will invest in our nation's airports
and that future calvin relief packages
continue to support
uh airports small concessions and
small businesses i'd look forward to it
one of the best parts of campaigning in
your state was getting to know the
extraordinary workers i know how much
they have been impacted by what's
happened and
you have my commitment to work together
to support them and of course we don't
have all those
businesses without the great travelers
that come for to
our wonderful especially southern nevada
for the las vegas convention center
and so we need to work on policies that
are going to
um increase the confidence in the
traveling public
business that we can have conventions if
they can go on vacation
and so uh how do you think that you're
going to work on trying to build some of
this confidence back in our
aviation safety after the pandemic and
promote
our tours and economy well the most
important thing i think is a perception
and a reality
of safety and air travel and the idea of
safety and air travel had
one kind of meaning a year ago it's
taken on additional meaning now in the
context of the pandemic
it's one of the reasons why i think
executive action on mass mandates is
so important and we should do everything
else that we can to
make sure that passengers know that
they'll have a safe experience which has
always been the mission of
the faa and the d.o.t but of course now
has taken on new meaning in the covet
era well thank you i appreciate that
i think i have time for one more
question so i want to talk about
something that we discussed a little bit
which is uh yucca mountain and nuclear
waste disposal
and uh you know nevadans we just refused
to let our
state be the nation's near dumping
ground
for 30 years we've opposed yucca
mountain nuclear waste disposal project
in part because it would require
transporting nearly 9 500
rail casts in 2800 trains and 26 000
i mean 2650 trucks across the country
to nevada this is a major transportation
crisis waiting to happen
it puts major metropolitan areas in 44
states
their freeways and their railways at
risk millions of americans
it will require 300 miles of new
railroad and take over
50 years 50 years at three loads per
week
by truck or by train to move all this
nuclear waste
so it's a huge um expense it's a huge
risk
and we have an aging rail system and
consistent shipments of these heavy
casts are just going to cause wear and
tear
uh let alone the safety and some of the
bottlenecks
if you go by train you have to go
through the same four major metropolitan
areas
three times a week for 50 years with
spent nuclear waste
i just think that would be unacceptable
to those four cities and
states as well so transportation you
have jurisdiction over the rail lines
jurisdiction on the transportation of
hazardous materials by rail
via your department's pipeline and
hazardous materials safety
administration
and its office of hazardous material
safety
so with that in mind giving the safety
concerns economic concerns
and that the fact that nevada has never
consented
to this project will you commit to
opposing dangerous shipments to yakima
uh i'm committed to making sure that
there's there are solutions that
everybody believes in and uh i share the
concerns that you've raised not just
from the nevada perspective but all
across the route
um and i hope i see that i'm over my
time i look forward to having
more discussions with you on that i
appreciate your
time here today your willingness to uh
serve our country i thank you for your
service and our military
and uh look forward to working with you
with uh
thank you so much thank you senator
rosen senator young
thank you mr chairman good to see you
again mayor
um in my introduction uh of you this
morning
i referenced a couple of projects i'm
very proud of uh because
uh during my tenure in the u.s senate
i've worked hard to secure funding for
and to elevate the importance of some of
the priority hoosier projects we have
uh around the state uh one of those uh
is the west lake corridor project of
which you're very familiar
uh the other the west uh rather the
south shore double track project that
you're even more familiar with
uh we have received a combined 500
million dollars in funding
as we look forward uh as you look
forward
uh we're looking at uh two major
projects
uh interstate 69 uh you're familiar with
that
in in the ohio river crossing from
evansville
over to henderson kentucky would you
commit to working with me
to uh try and and see those uh
projects to fruition and uh identify
funding streams in conjunction with an
infrastructure bill
very much forward look forward to
working with you on that okay and do you
think uh you might visit the state of
indiana
to say i'll turn up there from time to
time okay great great well um
i'll consider that a formal invitation
to come back home right sounds good
so one of the things we discussed on the
phone
as as uh we're discussing your
nomination some days ago
was stretching each federal dollar a
little bit further and identifying ways
to do that
and we we want to balance some equities
and public policy considerations here
and
and i know that's something both of us
take very seriously but the permitting
and review process i know can be
frustrating to
state stakeholders to local stakeholders
and probably even to some federal
officials in the building from time to
time
as we look at ways to improve
infrastructure we commit to working with
congress
to identify ways to streamline in a
responsible fashion
the federal permitting and review
process in order to
expedite safe project delivery of key
infrastructure projects
i think we should take every opportunity
to make sure that these processes are
efficient that
as much as is possibly uh doable
consistent of course with those safety
and environmental goals that they are
speedy that they're not duplicative and
i'd welcome ways to to work on that
together okay
one one specific opportunity i say
that i've identified to do that as have
others is is
uh nepa the national environmental
policy act
it's an important law it requires
federal agencies to consider the
environmental effects of proposed
federal actions this is an important
step in the overall process i just want
to underscore that
however it seems like maybe an area
that can be improved there's a recent
effort to make improvements to this law
in fact
last year the council on environmental
quality announced a final rule to
modernize
nepa and in that final rule they
established a two-year goal
for completion of environmental reviews
a time frame that
i think strikes most people as uh
reasonable
do you and the administration support
these recent efforts to set a
a two-year shot clock as it were for
completion of environmental review of
transportation
and infrastructure projects so uh nepa
is certainly something i encountered as
mayor came into play
of course on that south shore project
and uh i'm
aware of this uh adjustment that's been
made but want to learn a little bit more
about it i know it'll be on the agenda
for ceq and we'll make sure to be
at the table when that's being discussed
okay
we'll continue to work with you with
your indulgence
on on that effort because it's it's it's
something that strikes me as is a real
opportunity to
get more on time delivery and to stretch
those dollars a little bit further as
our constituents
uh would like us to do um i know funding
is
is uh what so much of this comes down to
as we discussed in our conversation
uh we're gonna have to work together
congress and the administration
on identifying proper funding mechanisms
one way that we might
leverage each federal dollar a bit more
is is by adopting
something that's been done in previous
infrastructure proposals the so-called
incentives program this incentivizes
state
and local governments perhaps regional
entities as well
to establish significant new non-federal
revenue streams dedicated to
infrastructure projects
what are your thoughts on the multiplier
effect that
an incentive uh program could create
by encouraging states to follow
indiana's lead frankly
and establish dedicated new revenue
streams for state
infrastructure projects i think that uh
it's really important to consider that
multiplier effect
a well-crafted program can leverage
dollars to do a lot more
as you point to we saw a lot of that in
indiana and my region benefit
and uh you know i think it's likely as
we see the
the scope and scale of the hoped-for
infrastructure
uh work to happen this year that we'll
have an opportunity to contemplate new
policy design on how to get that out the
door do you anticipate any counterpoints
or counter arguments to adoption of an
incentives program i'd want to make sure
that it's crafted in the right way
because i've found that anytime i think
something's a no-brainer somebody will
raise a concern
but certainly in principle that that
idea of leveraging dollars to get more
bang for your buck is one i
enthusiastically embrace well we too
have shot clocks
uh mine's only five minutes and i'm
already 30 seconds
over so uh i'll look forward to
continuing this conversation
and uh supporting uh your confirmation
thank you thank you
thank you very much senator young um
mr budder judge in terms of stretching
local dollars um one thing we've found
um in past
eras where interest rates were dropping
is that the use of advanced
refunding techniques uh
allowed state and local governments to
refinance
at lower interest rates while still
holding harmless the holders of the
bonds
are you familiar with this uh proposal
and do you agree
that this is one way to provide
additional
financing tools for state and local
thanks for raising that senator yes as
mayor a few things
uh gave me more uh fiscal uh pleasure
than to find that we could save taxpayer
dollars by
refunding uh a previously existing
debt especially since we of course do
our accounting on a cash basis
so i think this holds a lot of promise
for a relief to local government
i will tell you senator stabenow and i
had legislation during the last congress
that we were not able to get across the
finish line but
uh she and i will be working together
to try to uh make the case for this and
it would
i would appreciate it if you would do so
also um
i'm required to ask this question the
committee has a history
of asking nominees to state on the
record that they pledge to work with
congress
and the committee in a cooperative
manner so if confirmed
mr budder judge will you pledge to work
collaboratively
with this committee and provide thorough
and timely responses
to our request for information as we
work together to address
important policy issues i do and i will
thank you very much and uh i understand
you had a birthday earlier this week
that's uh that's true chairman right now
you ran for president united states were
you actually
uh constitutionally qualified not by
much but uh
just made the cut okay and and uh you
were on the tonight show last night with
jimmy fallon yes sir
and you're on the morning joe show this
morning
um in terms of of a
thrilling experience how does being
before this
committee today compared to those i
would characterize this as a unique
experience chairman
very well said um
i'm told that senator senator
cantwell um is um is finished with her
questions
and so i think it is appropriate now to
say that the hearing
record will remain open until the end of
this day
senators are asked to submit any
questions for the record by the close of
business today
thursday january 21 2021 the committee
asked the witness
upon receipt of any questions for the
record that you submit your written
answers to the committee
as soon as possible but no later than
close of business on
tuesday january 26
21 can you do that mr mayor
and let me check with staff and make
sure we have
guided all the eyes and crossed all the
teams
and with that i conclude the hearing
i thank the witness and thank members
of the committee for their cooperation
this hearing is closed
you